hello everybody markiplier here and I've
got a very special announcement that I
know a lot of you have been waiting for
for a long time and I'm so sorry for
this taking forever but I finally have a
P o box where you can send me whatever
you want to send me so here's the
address it's right here you can read it
here I'm gonna read it out make sure
that you guys get it right it is Mark
Fischbach that's my name my name is not
Mark Gibbler I got stupid last name of
that mark fischbach spelled correctly
P o box nine six seven seven at three
eight seven four Haxton avenue
cincinnati ohio 4-5 209 get all that
correct if you don't know how to send a
letter
well you're out of luck because I'm
not gonna explain it to you so send me
whatever you want if you want to send me
letters fan mail drawings um cookies
brownies food a big bear you know uh dog
crap in a bag don't send me that really
a mustache or something but don't rip a
mustache off someone that's really weird
don't do that whatever you guys want and
I'm gonna try to do more of these V logs
regularly trying to do at least once a
week so that I stay connected with you
guys I've been kind of getting bogged
down in just making content videos but I
gotta remember then I need to stay
connected to this community because this
community is growing into something
really amazing and I'm flabbergasted at
the response you guys have done an
incredible job the rate of growth is
insane we're about to hit 200,000
subscribers and I'm not even ready for
it I haven't done anything I've just
been busy with my own stuff and trying
to keep up with stuff and and I know if
you're sending me emails it's getting to
the point where so many people are
sending me emails now that I can't
respond to a long I am and just because
they don't respond doesn't mean I don't
read it
you know I I try to read everything I
just I can't always make a response so
I'm trying to keep up but it's just it's
it's it's crazy how many I'm getting so
thank you guys so much and I want you to
get involved more with this community
that we're building so if you haven't
already like me on Facebook and follow
me on Twitter I'm gonna try to use
Twitter more to actually talk with my
fans cuz that's a good way to do it make
it nice short messages so may be sure to
tag me and at markiplier if you want to
tell me something
obviously you can't write an essay so
that's even better so Facebook Twitter
links are in the description along with
the whole Bo box feel if you just want a
copy paste set you know you can do that
um also if you're an artist or any type
of artist doesn't mean drawing or
anything 3d artists or whatever there is
a fan deviantART page link is in the
description as well go there if you have
your own leaving art page you can post
your fan art of me if you think this
face is not ugly enough to not make fan
art of this is worthy then you can try
to put me down on paper maybe that'll
turn out into something that's not
terrifying
but also there is a fan tumbler which
you guys can follow for all you tumbler
heads out there and it is run by the
lovely Emily is Bach Foxtrot 44 next one
and by rain that you can follow them
individually but please follow that
tumblr they post all sorts of stuff that
gets passed around on
I still don't know how Templar works I
have one but I don't really use it all
that much so anyway follow their getting
involved and if you want to chat with
other fans directly and just so you can
stay up-to-date on what's going on
please go to the twitch chat on my
twitch channel it's down into the
description and you can actually um chat
live I'm not there a lot I used to be
but then I kind of got distracted and I
don't know I should be there more but if
you want to try find me and talk with me
directly if I'm there go ahead feel free
don't write big essays as always save
those for emails but anyway so those are
the ways that you can get involved with
this community and this can be community
that we're building is absolutely
incredible I am I'm so happy and honored
that you guys think that I'm worthy
enough to lead you to something I'm not
I never even considered myself to be a
leader but I've suddenly got a following
of over a hundred thousand almost a
couple hundred thousand now and I am I'm
hoping that I'm pointing you guys in the
right direction like I feel like you
believe in the causes that I believe in
with these charity streams in the
support that we can give for other
people and it doesn't even have to be
donating money sometimes we can just
bring attention to a project and that
that's more than enough but I'm really
honored that you guys think that I'm
worthy of that because I never imagined
it I never imagined we'd be growing this
quickly because when I started out I was
honored just that a couple hundred now
there's tens of thousands almost
hundreds of thousands of people and that
that it's daunting in a lot of ways so
I'm just I'm really grateful that you
guys have taken talk taken to heart
these causes and you guys understand
that we can do so much more for the
world around us so truly thank you all
so much that's pretty much it so that'll
do it for this feeling if you got
questions for me write them in the
comments I'll try to read through and
maybe I'll read it for the next V log
and I'm gonna try to put a regular
schedule on these things so that I can
stay in touch with you let you guys know
what's going on with my life
new updates and stuff like that and see
what surprises that you guys send me in
my PA box so send whatever you'd like
I'm looking forward to see what you got
for me
so thank you again everybody for
watching please please get involved with
the community there's a ton of great
people out there that you can get to
know so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye